is the shadow foreign secretary david
lammy hi thanks for joining us did the
government go far enough with its
sanctions
look there's a real issue about the
depth of the sanctions just three
russian
oligarchs there are 74 000 russian
people in this country the ons say
in the eu they said 27 why only three
and then there's a severity of the
sanctions
we should be
cutting russia out of the international
financial system that means getting them
out of the swift system dealing with uh
their currency and cutting them out of
the sovereignty to do that system you
cut them out of the sovereign debt
system the americans this is difficult
to do that isn't it
the swiss system is mandatory and
actually given that it's run from new
york and london we can make it happen we
haven't
the eu have put a travel ban on 351
members of parliament effectively um in
russia why haven't we done the same so
you have legislation in place to do that
yet serious are we about dealing with
sanctions was the question that was
coming up in the house of commons do we
have do we have the legislation in place
to be able to do that with
representatives from the tumor at the
moment well it was the legislation that
we debated yesterday that gives us the
framework to do that so we can do that
if we want to but we've got to be
serious about it
what do you want to see happen what
should happen to people like abramovic
and and the like because we did hear
from the prime minister that he had been
sanctioned then of course um he says he
misspoke and he will alter the record
accordingly
look
what we know is that there's dirty
russian money in london what we know is
that whilst vladimir putin might not
care about his own general public he
does care about money
and he and rich people associated with
him need to feel the squeeze
we know that i i'm not going to name
individual people on this show
because i would not be subject to
parliamentary privilege in the house but
we know the names and in the end coming
up with just three
feels very little too late
the um conservative government while
under uh boris johnson's tenure has
received millions of pounds
from
russian linked
donors
since he took office in october of 2019
i think i'm writing those dates um
should they give it back i did put that
to this trust she said no well she
didn't say no but she basically dodged
the question give it back
give it back send a message that we're
serious
um i'm sure it's not going to harm the
conservative party coffers it sends a
statement if the money is russian linked
if there's any suggestion that some of
it has come from oligarchs who might be
close to putin give the money back and
we said i said that weeks ago and they
haven't done it
what's going on with putin we
got the impression that he was trying to
negotiate the uh french president macron
said that he was looking to hopefully
put the two leaders when i say the two
leaders the u.s and russia together
as part of the summit we know that
lincoln from the u.s and lavrov from
russia was supposed to get together
tomorrow all of that is off now did he
never want a diplomatic solution you've
got to judge him by his actions and his
actions is an increased build-up on
ukraine's borders with more and more
troops
troops in a ready offensive position to
attack uh
we're not seeing de-escalation of course
we hope for peace and diplomacy in the
11th hour
but i think joe biden is right uh when
he says that
there can't be a summit whilst it's
clear that you're getting ready to
invade
the situation is very serious um
i'm fortunate in my job to get the
intelligence briefing we've got
very very uh considerable intelligence
capability it's very very worrying uh
what is happening on ukraine's borders
at this time tell us what you can tell
us as far as that briefing is concerned
do you think does the intelligence say
that there will be an invasion
it's very clear that if
russia wants to attack
it can
it's ready to go
and there has been no de-escalation
and actually the rhetoric from vladimir
putin himself just
48 hours ago in relation to ukraine its
history its lack of sovereignty the fact
that it's part
of russia that's in his head he thought
that
is indicative
of a language that we haven't seen
frankly from a european leader since the
1920s
early 1930s
the foreign secretary said that we were
expecting a full-scale invasion of
ukraine including an attempted attack on
kiev
would you um given what you've seen
would you agree with that yes if you
look at
where the troops are stationed around
the country uh if you look at the
numbers that are set if you look at the
air power missile power then very very
sadly
it feels like the ability to attempt to
take the whole country um is there and
that's why the west has to be very very
vigilant and to that end what should the
west do
if he does
we have to hit him hard financially
where it matters and where it hurts
and that's why i think in the british
house of commons there was concern
uh that the government's ratcheting up
is slow and that we're not sending the
message in a united way that we're
serious about damaging those are close
to him in the kremlin and dealing with
this issue of dirty money and what about
militarily
we're not committing
troops on the ground there is no
appetite for that in the west and it's
right that
um ukraine is not part of nato so that
is not the community but we did with
iraq
we're not making that commitment um and
actually when i was in kiev a few weeks
ago it wasn't actually what the
ukrainians were saying they were raising
issues around equipment and they're
readiness to fight they were thanking
the british for operation orbital where
we've been training them and helping
them and of course there's more we may
be able to do in relation to equipment
zielinski i know has asked for more uh
uh just in the last 48 hours but there
will not be a commitment of british
troops on the ground it's always great
to see in the flesh thank you very much
for joining us